in this video we'll talk about the
microbial culture media
we'll focus on the frequently used
culture media in medical laboratories
microbes need nutrients to grow just
like any other organism
and we'll classify the microbial culture
media on basis of different criterias we
can classify them on basis of their
chemical composition
there would be different classes like
simple media defined media or even
complex media
there could be classification which is
based on the physical nature of the
media like whether it is solid or liquid
there could be classification on basis
of their function such as supportive
media enriched selective or differential
media
in this video we'll talk about some
popular media that are frequently used
and which are of interest for medical
pathologists
so first we'll talk about simple or
basal media
here
these kind of media are used routinely
in labs and they are
generally used to grow non-fastidious
bacteria like
esterasia coli
enterobacter
and pseudomonas originosa
so
they have very simple composition they
need to have a carbon source a nitrogen
source and some salts
so generally they have beef extract or
yeast extract which can serve as
nitrogen source peptone and also they
have
salts such as sodium chloride
sometimes they have solidifying agent
such as agar
if we are talking about a solid media
so these kind of media is used to
primarily isolate microbes from patient
sample or let's say from other sources
example of these media includes nutrient
broth nutrient agar peptone water etc
now the
defined media or synthetic media are
slightly different from the simple media
both these media need to have
carbon and nitrogen sources but the
difference between these two media is in
defined media all these sources are
really defined
for example in simple media beef extract
or yeast extract
are kind of like undefined source of
nitrogen
but in case of
defined media all these proportions has
to be exact
let's talk about enriched media as the
name suggests there are additional
nutrients which are added in this media
such as blood serum
egg yolk etc so
enriched media is kind of like a basal
media that means the minimal requirement
for growth that means carbon source
nitrogen source salts etc along with
that some goodies are added to this
particular media
since several goodies are added to this
media these are useful to grow
nutritionally demanding bacteria or
nutritionally exacting bacteria such as
fastidious
organisms
now
example of such media are blood eager
chocolate egg
blood egger is preferred uh prepared by
adding of
five to ten percent of sheep blood
to the minimal media and this is
appropriate for the growth of
staphylococcus pneumonia
or many other organisms
now chocolate agar is one version of the
blood agar
where the plate is slightly heated and
the blood cells are lysed
among others hemophilus influenzae can
grow in this particular media
next let's talk about selective media
so in selective media
we designed this kind of media to
suppress the growth of one category of
microorganism while allowing the growth
of other category
selective media is agar based media and
generally individual colonies can be
isolated from this particular selective
media manitoba salt agar
salt milk agar etc are used for recovery
of specific organisms such as
staphylococcus aureus
so manitoba salt agar has
been used to
isolate staphylococcus aureus and
cephalococcus aureus colonies can
ferment manitol
and thereby
they have this characteristic yellow
colour in these colonies
more
examples involve mcconkey auger which is
selective as well as differential
culture media
so it is designed
to isolate gram negative and enteric
bacteria
and differentiate them from
differentiate based on like lactose
fermentation property so in a
mcconciagger all the lactose fermenters
would produce a pink colored colony such
as klebsiella enterobacter etc whereas
the lactose non-fermenters such as
salmonella shigella would produce a
yellow colony so based on color they can
be differentiated campylobacter agar is
another
aggro for uh selection so it's another
selective media
so campylobacter agar is dedicated for
isolation of campylobacter jejuni which
is found from the rectal or the
fecal swab
it has a cocktail of antibiotics such as
vancomycin polymix in b
all of these would allow the growth of
only campylobacter and reduce or inhibit
the growth of other bacteria in that
plane
now let's talk about another
differential media and this
media is known as differential indicator
media or chromogenic media so these
media are designed in such a way that
different bacteria can be recognized
based on their colony colors so
obviously chromogenic substrates are
used upon metabolism bacteria produce
different colors so in
simple words different bacterial colony
on the different in in that same plate
would have different colors and based on
that we can discriminate them
so a simple example was
uh
manitoba salt agar because manitoba
fermentation leads to a yellow colored
colony and this is very characteristic
of staphylococcus aureus
also you can think of the example of
mcconkey agar where lactose fermenter
versus lactose non-fermenters can be
discriminated based on their colony
colors
also we can talk about saboroids agar
which is used for
isolation of fungi such as candida
albiguns and
these are frequently used in the medical
laboratories to isolate fungus not
bacteria so it's another kind of
selective media
now we can classify media on based on
their chemical nature some media which
are frequently used they are solid media
generally they are in a plate and agar
is added into this media there are other
medias which are liquid media which
don't have um agar in that so they don't
solidify
so robertson's cooked meat is one kind
of like example so where
it is used for cultivation of aerobic or
anaerobic microorganism so let's say the
benefit of liquid media is you have some
patient sample but the amount of the
patient sample is very less so you have
a small swab
you can dip it inside a liquid culture
media and then allow it to grow for a
while and then from this
particular liquid culture media you can
inoculate in a
plate in a solid plate
and then it would allow the growth and
isolation of specific bacteria from that
plate
now from an industrial perspective
liquid culture systems are really
important because in industry
we can grow thousands of liter of
bacterial culture to get various
products such as think about the
antibiotic industry they need to grow
bacteria in bulk in order to extract
antibiotics from them also think about a
particular industry which involves
production of insulin or other kind of
recombinant proteins there then you need
to produce huge amount of biomass from
there they can extract that particular
product so from an industrial point of
view liquid culture is really important
so overall we learned the
most important type of
bacterial culture media used in lab if
you like this video give it a big thumbs
up don't forget to like